hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
the thunder imager em
cryo clem how to identify and retrieve
your cellular targets for cryo-electron
microscopy
i am christy jewell of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by leica microsystems
for more information on our sponsor
please visit
leica microsystems.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by using that ask a
question box
located on the left side of your screen
today's presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce today's
presenter dr john dubach
application manager correlative
microscopy at leica microsystems
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr deblock welcome you may now begin
your presentation
thank you christy for this very kind
introduction and
i welcome you to this webinar about how
we
from leica can contribute to to get a
better understanding of
cellular mechanisms or cellular biology
in general
and specifically i would like to explain
the role of our
cryo-white field microscope the thunder
imager em cryo clan
and the first question which might
appear in your mind is
why cryo why cryogenic conditions and
workflows under deep temperature are
important anyway and the answer actually
is this image here
you can see an image provided kindly by
benjamin angle from the max planck
institute in martin3 germany
and it shows a 3d view of the interior
of a cell
the nuclear membrane in grey with
nuclear
pore complexes in purple and
for example mitochondrion in orange
and different types of proteasomes
tethering to different sides of the
nuclear pore
and now why is such an image so
impressive
you've probably seen hundreds of
textbook schemes
in your life the difference is it's
not a textbook scheme it's a real
rendered image of
a of a real cell of an individual cell
examined in unprecedented resolution
and this answers the initial question
why cryo workflows are so important
because with this technique one can
resolve the interior of cells
and reveal the sociology of proteins
and other biomolecules with
sub-nanometer resolution
this really incredible and it was also
called a resolution revolution
it also shows the interaction of these
proteins
and the complete structural context in
the
3d volume examined
now which techniques are needed
to reveal such a cellular context
the following main steps are needed the
cells of interest are grown
or attached to an em grit and vitrified
vitrification is very fast freezing
without the formation of destructive ice
crystals
and of course after beautification all
steps have to be
under cryogenic conditions
and like this like this
with this vitification the proteins are
fixated but they stay in an
almost native state and then
structures of interest can be selected
and the selected areas
can be milled down by a specific
scanning electron microscope and this
scanning electron microscope
is shown here in this milling step it's
a focused
iron beam scanning electron microscope
or in short
fib sem and the thin ice sheet which is
remaining is
so called lamella you will probably see
that later in an image
this thin i see this lamella is then
transferred to a cryotm
transmission electron microscope and
tilted while observation to obtain
the 3d tomogram like shown before
so the last step is the 3d cryo
filmography
and with this little arrow on the right
hand
symbol you can see that the lamella is
tilted now
what has is to do with light microscopy
and how can
a light microscopy techniques by leica
contribute to achieve a 3d tomogram
and the question and the answer is
such workflows
have many steps and in particular
running an electron microscope is very
expensive and one must
validate the sample early in the process
and
this is to avoid unnecessary steps by
using a faulty specimen
so they are terribly expensive and
secondly
one needs to identify and retrieve
target structures which might be
invisible in the
in the sem and for this purposes a light
microscope or a particular fluorescence
microscope is essential
and it must be a cryogenic system
keeping the sample vitrified at all
times
during transfer and imaging of the sun
and i'm really proud to introduce to you
the thunder imager em cryoclam which
serves exactly these needs
the thunder imager cryoclam
is a fully motorized upright
camera-based microscope
and it belongs to a whole family of
imaging systems
providing the new leica thunder
technology
about thunder i will talk later
but and yeah of course um
the system is not completely new the
base of the system is um
was released 2017 and it's already the
third generation
of such a system and the customer base
is now more than 40 systems
globally
now coming back to the quality
assessment
of the sample
here you can see human fibroblasts
vitrified on an
em grid and under transmitted light
conditions one can identify
defects in the carbon film of the grid
here you can see such holes in the film
and one can see crystalline eyes these
more
dark patches in the image which would
disturb the milling process
and also the observation by the tm and
of course one can also identify suitable
areas
for em observation
and technically one can also
find the presence and distribution of
the target fluorescence
here of these beta one integrins
can be visualized in the yellow squares
now as one would like to exactly
retrieve these recent targets
in the sem it's very helpful to transfer
these coordinates
together with the image data towards the
sem
or to the tn and this is exactly what
our thundercryoclaim is
allowing we can transfer the image data
and the coordinates together
to for example seriallym which would run
mostly on tms
and for example also to thermo fisher
maps
software and then you just open one
one file with the image and the
coordinates
speaking of image data unfortunately in
a wide field microscope
blur can always be a problem
especially when imaging thicker samples
with for example
several cell layers and the reason is
that light from different optical planes
reaches
focal plane and is blurring the image
to reveal the hidden information leica
has developed the
thunder technology and thunder is an
up to digital method that removes this
autofocus blur
as you know all optical parameters of
our microscopes we can
very exactly determine where the light
originally was derived from and
we can provide also different methods
for specific sample thicknesses
and here you see the result on the left
hand side the
unprocessed image on the right hand side
the so-called standard image
now using thunder one can
identify target structures more
precisely
compared to standard images that's why
it's so important also for
targeting and the idea is
that the target structures later are
maintained in the lamella
so far we can provide the x y
coordinates
and one can retrieve the x y coordinate
in the
sem here you see this specific focused
ion beam sem in a
schematic drawing the electron beam is
coming from top for the observation and
the
focused ion beam removing
the upper and lower part of the
above and below the lamella is coming
here from
this angle now
here on the left hand side you can see a
pile of
this cells and exactly this pile of
yeast cell
itself was transferred to the milling
step on the right hand side you see the
same
target cell after the first
milling steps here and the um red
fluorescents here
are nucleoli and the green fluorescence
is the autofluorescence of the cell wall
and exactly this position here was
retrieved in the fib asia
the next image showed the same lamella
and
you see here the lamella and the context
of the em grid
the detail here in the center image
[Music]
are already in the transmitted electron
microscope and on the right hand side an
overlay
of the tm image and the fluorescence
the resulting tomogram at the end
would look somehow like this this is one
image of the tilt series
of a tomogram and
you can see it's a black and white image
fully packed with data actually which
has to be
reconstructed by sophisticated
software algorithms but this is exactly
one image
out of such a tomogram of the yeast
now finally
a tomogram would be reconstructed in
that way
like this first image i showed to you of
the
of the cell and the nuclear pores it's
not the same
tomogram of the yeast cell but such a
tomogram
could be reconstructed out of the raw
data
now what are the essential components of
the thunder imager
cryogam it's an upright camera-based
system as i said
and one of the crucial components is
the highly sensitive fluorescence camera
on top of the system
we have a cryo stage maintaining the
sample in a proper way
i will show an image in a second and
one of the most essential parts is of
course
the objective it's a dedicated cryo
objective with the highest numerical
aperture on the market and actually the
only
commercially available cryo objectives
the numerical aperture determines final
resolution that's why that is so
important and
0.9 is quite a high number for an
objective without any
immersion
of course we have to maintain the sample
safe under vitrified cryo conditions
and this is done by this patented
cryo stage here with lit on the left
hand side you see the lid
of that stage and the sample is kept
under gaseous nitrogen and
constant overpressure to avoid any
contamination by air moisture
the sample is loaded and transferred
intuitively by our transfer shuttle
which you can see here
and the grids are hosted in so-called
cottages you can see such a cartridge
for
bear grids and it can provide
cartridges for bare or unclip grids and
for clip grids
so-called how to grids
now how does the light microscope
integrate
into the workflow and what workflows
can we provide and the first
basic workflow actually um where we
started with
was the so-called cryoglim workflow
on the left-hand side you see the sample
and with this red circle
the target area is marked in a
symbolic way and the sample can be
nicely plunged frozen with our
fully automated web plunger the second
generation already it's called em
gp2 and then of course we can identify
and image the sample with thunder image
or em cryogen
and then finally we can directly
transfer the sample to cryo tm
and the coordinates
can be transferred via the software and
we have
several interfaces one i would really
like to mention is
the interface to serial em so we can
provide the coordinates
you mark on the light microscope
directly
to serial em and visualize it in series
em
and secondly also for thermo fisher
scientific maps
we were talking about cryotomography and
here i would like to show two workflows
first is this so-called flexible
tomography workflow and we are flexible
because
at the end you can use different types
of cryofib sims
and the start is the same
the pm grid here with a frozen sample
sorry this little sample it will be
vibified with the emg p2
you can identify and select and mark
the target positions with the thunder
imager e and cryoclam
and then you can transfer the sample
with the so-called
vcp but your cryotransfer system
vcp 500 and
use the vacuum cryo manipulation stage
you see here the emvcm
and then coding can be
applied a platinum protection layer
can be added prior to the fit milling
process
by the ema 600 or 900 and then we can
proceed to the cryofip and as i said
this can be
for example a jail scan or a size system
leica and thermo fisher can provide
another workflow it's so called
integrated workflow
depending on the fibs i'm used in this
case here it's the fibsim
by thermal fischer the thermofish of
scientific aquilas
and what is so special about this
workflow
first of all there is again the transfer
of the xy coordinates from the
cryolite microscope to the aquilos and
this is nicely done with a
one click import of an image file
containing the
image data and the coordinates here you
see two little screenshots on the right
hand side
of the software where we directly load
the
imaging coordinate file with one click
and the second advantage is the
hardware integration
of our cartridge and the grid cartridge
can be hosted by the flip shuttle
directly it the grids do not have to be
unloaded for the milling step and
this helps by reducing
unnecessary transfer steps here you can
see the
treble on the left hand side and
in the center you see the cartridge
which is already
clipped into the flip shot
and the more unnecessary steps
you reduce the more reliable the
workflow is
now coming to the benefits first of all
you can specify the sample by quality
assessment and fluorescence the
distribution
you can easily retrieve the target
regions
by having the interface between the
software and
the sample transfer is safer because
you have less steps you don't need to
unclip the auto grids
so we can provide hopefully a more
reliable workflow
and the target will be such a nice
rendered tomogram
coming back to the standard technology i
said that i would talk about this later
and
i would like to show you this image here
again here is the yeast example i showed
to you and then the clear lie here
are now much easier to identify because
the haze is removed
another example is shown here these are
hela cells kindly provided by lucy
collinson's lab
and you can see fibrous actin labeled in
red
and the trans golgi network probably in
the background here
in this yellowish color and nucleoli a
nuclei in blue
and the thunder results are clearly
visible
when i click the next slide and you can
see how
the actin fibers appear and the
transcology network is really nicely to
discriminate
from the background
now what is the thunder technology
thunder
is like us proprietary development and
it's
an opto digital method called
computational clearing
and as you can see it applies to 2d
images but also of course to 3d images
and core technology is this
computational
clearing we can provide different
methods for
different sample types and
tundra automatically takes all relevant
optical parameters into account
on top to the core technology which i
said is this instant computational
clearing
[Music]
we also apply a so-called
decision mask technology
and this is called whether
small volume computational clearing or
large volume computational clearing
depending on the
sample thickness and the decision mask
detects the local signal
over the image and preserves it that's
very important to know because then
you can actually run a fully automated
deconvolution
independent actually of your manual user
input
it's very nice already with the first
click you obtain
very nice results and as said you can
provide specific methods for more
thicker of
thinner thumbs okay of course
um the thunder imager cryoclam is part
of a whole
family of thunder images and we can
we can provide powerful system solutions
for any of your core life science
applications you might have
for example here on the left hand upper
panel you can see the thunder image on
for model organisms
you can see a dedicated system for
tissue slices
but also 3d tissue 3d cell culture
for example steroids and
of course also for more assay-based
applications and the thunder imager
cryoclam
serves to your needs in the cryo or more
in the
em related fields
further information on thunder you can
have through
these links here we have a nice
technology node that you can
get more deep insight into the
technology we provide
a very nice image gallery with many
examples
how thunder improves your image quality
here are some recent citations using the
predecessor of the thunder imager the
so-called eem cryoclam
kindly provided by the embl by reina
kaufman's group and
also by liz wright's lab
if you want to see the system live for
the usi we can provide two reference
centers one
is at ucsd university of california san
diego
in elizabeth vias group and
the other one is at yay university the
west campus
junior in all other
customers in other regions across the
globe
are kindly invited to germany whether to
the max planck institute
in martin street the baumeister lab in
jurgen klitschko's group
or the european molecular biology lab
the embl in heidelberg
in the em facility with
janik schwab
and with this i would like to finish
my presentation and thank you very much
for your attention and
i'm open now for questions you might
have
thank you dr debac for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
okay let's get started we have so many
great questions already coming in
dr debacle let's start with this one can
you do targeting in
x y and z
thank you christie that's an excellent
question i also saw it
quite often in the list right now
we can provide x y z
image stacks and
the coordinates only in x y so we are
working on getting this done but right
now we are
providing the coordinates in x y
but of course we can provide a complete
3d z-stack
of the light microscope and in some
softwares already
you can load the the 3d stack and you
can get a glimpse
on the 3d distribution of the
fluorescent target
and for example in thermos visual maps
you can slide through the
fluorescent slides and get a better
impression
where to target the lamella
thank you dr buck can i export the
coordinates
to other fib sem than the
thermo aquilos
yes you can do that
we provide an xml file
with the coordinates and as
long as the manufacturer of the em
can read this xml file they can get the
coordinates
according to the center of the image
that's
i think already possible for tescan for
example
they just um looked at the xml file and
imported the coordinates
can i also combine this workflow with
the vct500 from leica
and yes i think i showed one of the
images in the flexible workflow
give me one second um
i hope that you can see that on the
screen now you see in the center
um a device with a rod
sticking out to the left hand side this
is the
vcm system and the rod is actually
attached to the
vct vct means vacuum cryotransfer system
which has a little dewer inside and can
nicely
transfer the sample under cryogenic
conditions
and as soon as you stick it here to this
vacuum cryo manipulation station the vcm
you can also see the temperature and the
state of the vacuum so you're always
sure
how the state of your sample is during
transfer
thank you dr depak what does that sender
processing
actually do what does it do exactly
thank you for this question um it also
came into my mind when i first
saw the first slides um when thunder was
released
and um it's it's a long story but i i
will keep it short and so
the the heart is the computational
clearing here and
it detects and removes the out of focus
background
light for each image and this makes the
the
signal of interest directly accessible
at the same time
in the in focus area the edges of the
signal
and the intensity of the spectrum
features
remain intact that's important because
you
just not do a background subtraction
where you lose also signal
but you really keep the features of your
sample
intact that's why you also can
[Music]
select the feature size and expected
feature size
and secondly
one question was there uh how the
resolution of
thunder can how does thunder improve the
resolution
and it does it uh shows the resolution
enhancement
in um x y so lateral
laterally uh two times and
actually um 2.5 times and this means
defined as by the apparent size of a
point source emitting light
so we cannot separate two structures
which
are close to each other below the
diffraction limit but
of course we can improve the resolution
in all dimensions
dr deback what would be the advantage of
using cryo clem
confocal boat based compared to
ws thunder
very good question um of course a wide
field system
does not deliver the same axial the same
z
resolution as a confocal and a confocal
would improve
even the actual resolution even more
and we can provide also a cryo-confocal
system and if you plan to
to to purchase such a system please get
in contact with one of our local
leica colleagues
because we handle these projects project
by project
and we can provide it and the actual
resolution is even more
improved
thank you is the 50 times objective the
only
option what if we need a higher
magnification
um yeah the 50 times objective indeed is
the only option because it's our
dedicated cryo objective
and unfortunate is already has
a numerical aperture of 0.9
and if you want to go higher actually
you need
immersion and of course under cryo
conditions immersion
is quite tricky there are some um
systems out there which are not
commercially available
but it's kind of tricky to really work
with immersion
so the 50 times objective is our um
objective
of choice and um we also use that for
the controller system
now doctor boss debac this is a little
lengthy question but i'm i'm
going to read it if you need me to
repeat it i can now here's a question
about
workflows and sorry this may be a naive
question because i'm not an expert in
tomography
or these new techniques but why is it
necessary to do coding of the sample
before fib and cryotomo
or that example is if you want to do sem
i thought you could take the fib lamella
directly and put it in the cryomic
microscope to obtain the tomograms
yeah so the question is quite good
the milling process so is quite
harsh to the sample or could be harsh
because your direct
focused iron beams so you direct iron
iron beams on the sample
in a focused way and you really remove
material
and if you would not protect actually
the surface
and therefore the the edge of the the
lamella created
you would actually remove also a part of
the actual lamella you want to achieve
and by this um to avoid this you have to
protect it by this platinum layer
that you get a nice sheet which is not
destroyed
thank you now dr gerbach do you have any
examples of bacterial samples
such as individual bacteria micro
colonies biofilms
yeah thank you for this question we
already
had several machine demonstrations
with bacteria and you can nicely resolve
single bacteria
even the distribution
of the fluorescence along the bacterial
axis for example
that was nicely
[Music]
visualizable one can say yeah
thank you now dr debac thank you for
your talk
do i understand correctly that the
thunder is
only a digital technique applied after
acquisition
so the imaging itself is still standard
wide field
that's exactly the case so on this
system
we we
do a post-processing funder so you don't
need to necessarily
do the thunder processing afterwards um
but of course it's it's very fast
because it's over like a proprietary
technique
and we actually developed um
this technique also for life samples
that the
the thunder process is is applied
directly kind of
in real life exactly so it's really
a fast technique excellent thank you
now we do have time for a few more
questions but i do want to let our
audience know that any questions we are
unable to answer
live today and additionally those
questions that are submitted during the
on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration so let's get
squeeze in some more questions here
dr debac what is the difference between
thunder clearing
and deconvolution
so um we refer to thunder
actually as as both techniques
the first part is the computational
clearing so removing the background
which is inherent to white field images
and a second part is
what i what i showed to you the small
volume computational clearing and large
volume computational clearing
probably i can show you the images the
related images
so the core technology is the instant
computational clearing
removing the background and keeping the
true spatial dimensions
and then in the second step actually we
do
this decision masked technology
deconvolution
so we really run what we say a
structural element over this the sample
and we look where is background where
signal and
yeah we kind of do a fully automatic
deconvolution so actually
a manual input is not really necessary
but of course you can tweak on the the
settings a little bit according to your
specimen thank you
now i have a two-part question for you
can multiple targets be identified on a
single
grid and what is the time needed to mill
a lamella
the first question i can refer to so you
can
define as many targets as you want of
course
you can also have different uh
lamellar targets on one grid
um actually the next generation for
example the axillos can do an automatic
milling
and you can have i don't know 10 20
lamellar mills automatically on one grid
depending on the sample position
inside of grid squares and
the milling time i'm a light microscopy
expert but i
if i look over the shoulder of somebody
who is milling it
um it needs uh it can need
half an hour or sometimes longer
depending on how thick the sample is
but it's in the range of yeah probably
less than half an hour
um yeah in that range
[Music]
um
sorry can you repeat the second part i
can't yes that's i'm just going to ask
you
what is the time needed to mill a
lamella
oh yeah okay i refer to that already
yeah thank you
okay very good all right our next
question
is it possible to use a microscope at
room temperature
or is it only usable at cryotemps
you can just use the system also under
room temperature conditions
no problem as long as
you use grids so you can
load probably can show this in the
correct
slide here as you can see on the slide
you um load these little cartridges with
them
with a with the grids loaded and
we cannot really apply normal slides or
so
for this you would have to remove the
cryo stage here
of the on top of the motorized stage
and yeah have a sample order here
but normally we would just use grids
on the system
and dr dabak what are the yes what are
the prospects
of integration with the joule cryoarm
system
um so i probably answered this question
already
the coordinate file and the image
file are in a standard format
this means the images are exported in
tiff format or o and etf or
e stands for open microscopy environment
tiff
so you can select actually the the
format you want to have
it can also be exported as bitmap or
jpeg but i think these are not
very common in this sense and
the coordinates so the marker
coordinates can be exported as
xml standard file and as long as the
em manufacturer can read these xml files
they can also load the coordinates of
course together with the
integrated workflow here together with
thermo fisher
we actually load um one file
where the images and the coordinates are
already in
and it's just one click and everything
is loaded the correct histograms the
correct lookup tables
the coordinates and it directly snaps to
the
sample holder scheme in thermo visual
maps so this is kind of the first steps
already of a fine
correlation and just by one click
thank you our next question is two parts
what samples beyond cell culture and
yeast
has this workflow been validated for
and could it be used for plant tissue
samples for example
a small portion of a leaf
very good question again thank you for
all these questions they are really
relevant and
also um help to
to really give you a better picture of
the system um
as said we already had um samples like
yeast uh
any single cell uh which you can imagine
imagine
whether they are um grown on em grits or
deposited we already had
bacteria and you can also have
bigger samples as long as you can
nicely vitrify them and the first
technique for that would be high
pressure freezing of grits but also
of course grid plunging and as long as
you can
vitrify them properly we can look at
them
and together with the thunder technology
we can also examine sticker sound just
like only
two cells or so two cell layers so we
can
also use thicker samples
thank you and i did see a question come
in multiple times it's is
this webinar being recorded and it can
can it be reviewed again
can be viewed a second time and yes it
is being recorded
and we will send you an email shortly
when this is available for replay
and you can share that link with all
your colleagues and
friends who may have missed today's
event and let's wrap with this final
question dr debac
how long could we keep the vitrified
grid
on the stage of the optical microscope
actually what
the max planck institute did they just
checked
how long can they keep the sample on
this on the
on the stage during imaging and without
imaging
before seeing uh spectral contaminations
and they found out that uh after seven
hours
so this is really a long long period
they
they saw um contamination so this means
you can do imaging and you can keep the
sample um
for several hours without any compromise
here
on the system
dr debak thank you so much for this
excellent q a do you have any final
comments you'd like to leave our
audience with
so thank you all for joining and for
this um
this really very well asked questions
um all the questions which appear here
will be answered
and we get in touch with you
and if you want to see the machine in
action
please contact your local leica
colleague or
just write us an email no problem
we will get in touch with you and really
thank you very much
for joining this webinar it was a great
pleasure for me
and please stay healthy in these times
and i hope that we can
see in person see each other in person
at least some of you i saw some familiar
names here on the list as well
thank you thank you also to you
christine
oh and thank you dr debac and before we
go i do want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
we had so many questions that we were
unable to address
today live so as dr debach did mention
we will be addressing them via your
email address that you provided at the
time of registration
also please continue to submit those
questions during the on-demand event
just come on back it's available for
unlimited on-demand viewing and you can
continue to submit those questions and
they will be answered
via email i'd also like to thank
dr yonder bach for his time today thank
you so much for joining us and for your
important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's
educational webcast as i mentioned this
webcast can be viewed on demand
and we'll send you an email shortly
letting you know when it's available for
replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
we thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon stay healthy
and have a great day
you